would you rather you have your  girlfriend's hair or she has your hair  oh dee academy jared leto's my spirit  animal i'd [ __ ] rather have her hair  she used to have pink hair do me with  long pink hair bro we talked about on  the show harry styles be all over me  dude and that's my goal man i'd be such  a dime piece as a gay dude these [ __ ]  jeans i dress like it i didn't know this  fits not cool in new york someone called  me the f word a [ __ ] third street man  i don't have it on now i wear a fanny  pack too okay someone called me the  f-word when's that  the what  in public  i was like wait what did you say what'd  you do  sorry in cali i'm a solid nine  in new york i'm a four